je me tourne d'abord vers vous docteur
charbonnel est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
dites oui
l' agence européenne du médicament a
déclaré aujourd'hui que le vaccin
astrazeneca était sûr était efficace est
ce que vous ou l'administré santé alors
oui on prend deux ministres restons de
le plus clairement justement ce qu'on en
a repéré sur un nombre très important de
gens vaccinés des situations médicales
dont on ne savait pas trop ce que
c'était ça arrive avec tout les premiers
de santé commercialisés tout le temps
c'est les études de phase cad s'est fait
comme ça et de temps en temps on ne se
voit que tu tiens il ya un truc qui
cloche et puis ça attire le satyre
l'oeil de tout le monde et dans tous les
autres cas quand ça attire l'oeil de
tout le monde on dit on va renforcer la
surveillance on va regarder ce qui se
passe mais le process est tellement
important que sur tout le laisse se
dérouler et le nombre de cas qui était
identifiée c'est la même situation qu'on
a eues avec les anti-inflammatoires tout
au début de la maladie on s'est dit
tiens tiens un truc étonnant
et puis on s'est aperçu en reprenant les
études les calculs les machins que n'y a
aucun risque
donc il n'ya pas de produits qu'ils
soient parfaitement fiable on peut pas
démontrer mais mathématiquement qu'un
produit est parfaitement fiable ce qui
est certain c'est que il fait prendre un
exemple que je prends ailleurs les
autoroutes s'est limité à 130 le risque
que vous prenez
avec la phrase et mika c'est de rouler à
131 132 sur l'autoroute le risque que
vous prenez à ne pas vous vacciner c'est
de rouler à contre sens sur le tour donc
la vérité elle est là ça n'est pas
compliqué il n'y a pas un produit qui
est totalement anodin mais par contre en
le risque de ne pas vacciner au prétexte
qu'il ya eu un petit doute sur un tout
petit produit quand on voir enfin on en
est à 350 morts par jour depuis des mois
était bon c'est pas une bonne année pour
revenir au début de votre raisonnement
il ya des risques avec tous les produits
mais astrazeneca ne présente pas des
risques supplémentaires selon vous non
seulement ils présentent pas de risques
supplémentaires mais le bénéfice qu'ils
apportent
et dans tout ce qu'on avait souvent
comment s'appelle justin poindre de
rappel la vaccination c'est toute la
chaîne de soins qui est en cause c'est
dire que c'est les infirmières les
généralistes les kinés etc
quand je quand j'entends dire que
l'erea sont débordés c'est pas les réacs
qui sont les bancs d'essai l'ensemble du
système de santé qui est débordée des
infirmières libérales jusqu'au
réanimateur et pourquoi je suis
tellement persuadé qu'il faut vacciner
c'est parce que cette vaccination c'est
de toute manière actuellement la seule
solution réaliste qu'on a mais l'on
parle d'un vaccin en particulier pas de
la vaccination en général on assure
vaccins en particulier strazeele seul
qu'on a pour l'instant donc moi je veux
bien que 10 demain on n'a pas le seul
moi j'en ai pas et je pense qu'il n'est
pas raisonnable de prendre le risque
d'attendre quand on a vu les chaînes
d'approvisionnement ce que ça donnait
donc on vaccine avec ce qu'on a et le
risque qu'on prend en vaccinant avec la
soie zeneca il est peanuts mais la
communication politique qui a été faite
cette semaine vous n'imaginez pas à quel
point c'est une catastrophe
j'étais en train de vacciner bien sûr
l'un des 5000 6000 m'a dit attendez il
ya le président est bien de dire c'est
marqué sur twitter il faut arriver